that's Jay no that is hunter last public  photo of hunter zolomon instantly  recognizable people from my earth  admirer of serial killers aren't anomaly  so a lot of media attention to this was  a podcast when Hunter was 11 his father  killed his mother right in front of them  father sent to prison Hunter grew up in  the foster care system years later he  was convicted on 23 counts of murder 23  that's like some real Hannibal Lecter  type level after the trial I never sent  to the Saint Perez mental asylum for the  criminally insane  given daily electroshock therapy you  remember sergers and then faded from  view until the night your particle  accelerator exploded that's right  Dark Matter crept in in the mental  asylum I thought piping the explosion  underground would limit exposure I was  wrong all the did was create an  unstoppable monster flash all new  tonight at 8:00 7:00 central on the CW